♪♪♪
♪ LOVE.. LETS TALK ABOUT LOVE ♪
♪ IS IT ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING YOU HOPED FOR ♪
♪ OR DO THE FEELING
HAUNT YOU... ♪
♪ OR DOES THE FEELING
♪ CAUSE MAYBE THE NIGHT THAT MY
DREAMS MIGHT LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER
ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ MAYBE THE NIGHT THAT MY
DREAMS MIGHT LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS GET CLOSER
ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ TELL ME WHAT YOU
GON' DO TO ME ♪
♪ CONFRONTATION AINT
NOTHING NEW TO ME ♪
♪ YOU COULD BRING A BULLET ♪
♪ BRING A SWORD,
BRING A MORGUE ♪
♪ BUT YOU CAN'T BRING
THE TRUTH TO ME ♪
♪ FUCK YOU AND ALL
YOUR EXPECTATIONS ♪
♪ I DON'T EVEN WANT
YOUR CONGRATULATIONS ♪
♪ I RECOGNIZE YOUR FALSE
CONFIDENCE AND CALCULATED ♪
♪ PROMISES ALL IN YOUR
CONVERSATION ♪
♪ I HATE PEOPLE THAT
FEEL ENTITLED ♪
♪ LOOK AT ME CRAZY CAUSE
I AINT INVITE YOU ♪
♪ OH YOU IMPORTANT ♪
♪ YOU THE MORAL TO THE
STORY YOU ENDORSING ♪
♪ MUTHAFUKA I DON'T
EVEN LIKE YOU ♪
♪ CORRUPTED MANS
HEART WITH A GIFT ♪
♪ THATS HOW YOU FIND OUT
WHO YOU DEALING WITH ♪
♪ A SMALL PERCENTAGE
WHO I'M BUILDING WITH ♪
♪ I WANT THE CREDIT IF I'M
LOSING OR IM WINNING ♪
♪ ON MY MAMA THATS
THE REALIST SHIT ♪
♪ LOVE.. LETS TALK ABOUT LOVE ♪
♪ IS IT ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING YOU HOPED FOR ♪
♪ OR DO THE FEELING HAUNT YOU ♪
♪ OR DOES THE
FEELING HAUNT YOU ♪
♪ CAUSE MAYBE THE NIGHT THAT MY
DREAMS MIGHT LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER
ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ MAYBE THE NIGHT THAT MY
DREAMS MIGHT LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS GET CLOSER ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER
ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ GETTING COLD WHEN AN EGO GETS
TO TALKING I GET INVOLVED ♪
♪ LIKE A WEED BLOWN
NO CONTROL NO ♪
♪ I'M SWITCH IN A WAY THAT YOU
BRINGING ME DOWN ♪
♪ IT'S A TURN ON YOU
DIDN'T WAIT FOR ME ♪
♪ LEAVE ME ALONE
KEEP AWAY FROM ME ♪
♪ AND IT SOUND WRONG
GET IT AWAY FROM ME ♪
♪ YEAAAA ♪
♪ I JUST CRIED FOR NO REASON I
JUST PRAY FOR NO REASON ♪
♪ I JUST THINK FOR THE LIFE FOR
THE DAY FOR THE HOURS ♪
♪ AND ANOTHER LIKE BREATHING ♪
♪ I DID IT ALL BUT
IT FEEL GOOD ♪
♪ YOU LEFT IT ALL IF
IT FEEL BAD ♪
♪ BETTER LIVE YOUR LIFE ♪
♪ WE BEEN RUNNING OUT OF TIME ♪
♪ (VOCALIZING) ♪
♪ CAUSE MAYBE THE NIGHT THAT MY
DREAMS MIGHT LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER
ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ MAYBE THE NIGHT THAT MY
DREAMS MIGHT LET ME KNOW ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS GET CLOSER ♪
♪ ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER
ALL THE STARS ARE CLOSER ♪
♪ ♪